I think there's a workshop which will be
entirely devoted actually to
reinforcement learning in many different
perspectives I also like to remind you
that at the end of the day we're going
to have the panel panel it's not
specific about the person cleaning but
about the themes of the workshop to do
there's a link here on the whiteboard
if you want to either submit questions
in the panel or both of which questions
like computer and answers ok so now
we're going to begin with the first stop
of the day by knives young and hardness
of reinforcement learning with value
function approximation
yeah great thanks yeah it's my great
pleasure to be here you see and today
I'll be talking about some of my recent
work and value function approximation
aro okay so you know as all of us know
ro is the machinery and paradigm for
sequential decision making and it finds
many actual applications in a wide
variety of scenarios including like
robotics systems resource allocation
support and in recent years we've seen
inspiring success empirically of the
application of RL in game playing
domains so today I'll be talking about a
particular sub sub area of RL known as
the value function approximation and so
this is the theme of this workshop is
emerging challenges in deep learning and
I guess machine learning in general and
so today what I want to revisit is some
of the simplest the most fundamental
setting of reinforcement learning and
revisit some of the theory that has been
around for a long time and it turns out
that there's too many widely open
problems that need to be resolved so
what's better polish approximation so so
roughly speaking so this is the setting
where you use a restricted class of
functions to approximate what we call it
optimal value function Q star of a
dynamic environment I will define these
terms more formally later okay and we're
gonna consider the batch mode learning
again like a more formal description
will follow so in The Bachelor Ning
setting you so you know URL you interact
with the environment right but in the
matter of batch mode learning setting
you get some data passively from that's
are generated from the environment and
you're supposed to learn a good policy
just from the data you're given and you
have no further interactive access to
the
so why do we care about bash mode VFA
well it turns out that bash mode vfa is
kind of like the theoretical backbone
for many popular deeper algorithms today
for example DQ n so although those
algorithms they do have access to the
environment and can accurately explore
what you usually do is that you hook up
a batch learning algorithm with a simple
heuristic exploration kind of like a
mechanism like absent greedy which we
know are inefficient in the worst case
so you really would you really
so those methods they really succeed
because these methods because somehow
like the environment is easy to explore
so you get good data and the bash
learning component actually succeed when
you have export or data so you really
need to understand why Batchelor nning
succeeds - to understand why those
algorithms
in this talk I'll be focusing on a
single question that is under what
assumptions and in particular I would
like to have the minimal set of
assumptions that so that we can
guarantee sample patient learning so be
purely be considering sample patients so
so to give you a more concrete sense of
what I mean or what kind of results that
I'm looking for I'm drawing a comparison
to the most basic and fundamental result
instead of soaring theory so this is
something like there's a learning theory
101 that you were teaching in a day 1
class of like a learning theory class
right so so so in supervised learning
let's consider the single setting where
we have ie input-output pairs that are
drawn from a distribution and the
simplest setting is where like you have
a class of predictors F that predicts Y
from X here X Y can be binary labels or
like real bad it would or real bad it
doesn't matter right so let's for now
assume that AB is finite and one of them
makes good predictions so the most the
simplest the result that lays the
foundation for the entire mention of
learning theory or at least one of the
those fundamental results is the polling
right it says that if you give me log ab
number of samples I can't find a good
predictor out of this class and this is
the information theory as theoretical
results because we're ignoring
computation for now and you can get this
just by simply like empirical risk
minimization so this is the this is the
simplest the result for supervised
learning and what I really want is that
I want the analogy of this kind of
result for the RL sitting right it's
like simple basic assumptions and then a
clean result so let's first anticipate a
little bit of what that result couldn't
look like right so recall that we're
thinking about Bosch mode value function
approximation
it's a batch mode we're gonna have some
data instead of like input-output pairs
in RL the data would look like something
like state action reward next a tuple
tuples and I would define how they're
generated in a second
and there's one for the assumption that
that need to be made is that the status
that needs to be exploratory and I will
formally define what that mean in a
second okay and similarly we're gonna
have a class of candidate value
functions F yeah we're gonna assume that
this is finite and one of them is the Q
star the optimal value function that we
want to capture or want to approximate
so the essential question we want to
answer is under these these seem like
three minimal assumptions for this set
up I want to understand if these
assumptions are sufficient for
guaranteeing Sampo efficient learning
and here by simply efficient I mean that
I only want to pay logarithmic in F
number of samples I'm omitting another a
few other parameters here which I would
define later for example the horizon of
the problem is also needs to appear here
but roughly speaking that's the is the
this is the high level picture that I
want to get in the end
so so it turns out so you can and
particular that the key is something
here is that we're assuming what we call
a realizability right we have a function
class that captures the function the
target function that we want to
approximate okay so the key question is
are these assumptions sufficient okay so
and people have been studying the
setting for I don't know more than 20 or
30 years and as far as I know the answer
to this question is that we don't know
okay so I think there so this is what
I'll be talking about in the rest of
this talk I think we have pretty
reasonable evidence to believe that
these assumptions are English
insufficient in particularly for the
representation condition you need
something that is much stronger than
realizability but we don't really have a
counter example or an algorithm agnostic
lower bound against like the current
setup and sorry yeah go ahead leaning to
maximize modular function basically what
is like the end result is today the
function classes it's a modular for
simple ones for which you can know how
to learn you know how to maximize but
for example I am not familiar with that
body literature not sure so
well I go more deeper into this engine
maybe you can bring it up later if you
find it so so to get deeper into this
question I want to formally define all
these like uh vague notions and
notations over here so that we have a
more formal mathematical setup to
discuss so we're gonna as usual we're
gonna consider Markov decision processes
think of this as a multi-step decision
procedure where we're gonna have each
episode and within each episode there
are time steps so so you start observing
some state s1 from a state space big s
and for now we're because we're thinking
of function approximation the state
space this state space is assumed to be
very large in the sense that you cannot
pay any dependents on the size of the
state space that's like and after
observing the current stage the learner
will choose an action eh from the action
space and you get some intermediate
reward as a function of the current
state and the current action so it's a
there's a reward function and then you
transition stochastically to the next
stage sh-sh plus 1 based on SH and H and
that's defined by their transition
dynamics and you keep doing this for a
number of time steps it can be a finite
or infinite with this guy so the
ultimately what you want is to find a
policy pi that map's States to actions
and the measure of goodness of policy is
defined as the scalar which is the
discounted sum of reverse in expectation
when you follow this policy you take
actions using this policy and you start
from some given initial state
distribution mu 0
and here this gamma is a discount factor
that kind of like translates like how
long this the decision-making is or how
many time steps do you need to make
decisions to finish in episode so within
this talk I'll be like switching back
and forth or use the finite horizon on
discounted case MVP and the infinite
horizon discounted case kind of like
interchangeably because they're not
really like that much different from
each other so if you want to think it
conveniently think of it as like each
step decision process you make each step
you make eight decisions and the episode
ends and you restart from the initial
stages fusion and yeah so new 0 is the
initial state distribution for example
if you're playing the game you say you
play the game of go then apparently the
initial state is like the empty board
and here we're we're thinking of like
the episodic tasks where the internal
state is what what if I just as a kind
of like a visual example or think of
likes as game playing and here will be
getting stay that are like say and your
action will be control signals that you
send to the game and intermediate
immediate rewards will be the game
points that you get off for the current
time step and then your transition to
the next state which is the next game
screen and this transition can be a
stochastic because for example some of
the random game mechanisms and you want
to learn a policy that helps you what
button to put to press given the current
game screen
so and we're doing because we're going
to do battery function approximation so
it's very important to introduce some of
the key solution concepts so the key
code solution costs have the optimal Q
at a function that I just mentioned
previously is this function over here it
says that starting from a state and
action if you start from this state s
and you take the first action as a and
after that you behave optimally we're
maximizing over all possible ways of
behaving for the remaining actions a2
all the way to a infinity what's the
expected value that you can get so this
is the this is a very central concept to
reinforcement learning for two reasons
the first reason is that if you if you
obtain this value function you will
immediately get the optimal policy
because you can just simply behave
greedily according to you this Q star or
at any state s you take the action that
maximizes Q star of Si and that's the
optimal policy so this is it's like if
you get this function you're down and
furthermore this function is in some
sense kind of like easier to find it
sense that it satisfies what we call a
bellman equation okay so this is the
famous pre support for optimality that
says that the optimal value you get in
the current state is equal to the
immediate reward plus the optimal
discounted future value for the next
time step explanation so here this is
the immediate reward and here we're
taking expectation over future optimal
values over the transition probability
from the ground state in action
and you realize that this is like a
fixed-point equation q star appears on
both ends both sides of the equation and
it's nonlinear because there's a max
operator so the the existence of this
bellman equation is kind of a crucial to
particularly like our policy learning
from just the okay so this is the basic
RF setup
yeah relationships so they both have a
max but I think because of the state the
policy is quite different I think the
connection was that Sambhaji
maximization and the bellman equation of
the Matsui support there's a model of
simulations much easier right
okay so this is the kind of like an MTP
setup and now we're going to the
learning setting right so we're learning
the policy from samples so I have to
tell you like how do i generate the data
and how do i approximate the target
function is also our data set is the bag
of tuples of state action reward next
state tuples and for simplicity I will
assume that they're kind of like the ID
setting VAR l where the SI pairs are
drawn from ID from a fixed distribution
mu which I'll call the data distribution
and we have need some assumptions on
this distribution basically we need this
distribution to like fully currently
interstate action space to that later I
never come once you Joe state action you
generate the reward and random next
state according to the MDP dynamics okay
this is our data and for learning we're
gonna have a function class f that
captures Q star this is a realizability
and we're gonna assume that F is finite
and we want to only pay logarithmic
dependence on the cardinality of that so
the final goal is that we want to learn
a function f that is approximately that
is approximate Q star such that is
scooti policy is near optimal and recall
that by near optimality I mean that if
you evaluate the policy that you find
with this evaluation metric it is
absalom close to the best that you can
get we're always talking about the
scalar expected return on there they're
given a tional state distribution for
just for the single under the epsilon
close under the initial state
distribution not for every single state
States should be epsilon close to the
optimum no no no that's
so it's or think about this way so it's
without loss of generality you can think
of this this episodic problem starting
from a single initial state let's say
the in-game of go is the empty board all
I want is that my policy is absolutely
close to the optimal policy when
evaluate it in the initial state that is
you play the game under the starting
from the empty war I get as high winning
rate as the policy and they say that's
the the reason is that you don't expect
to get like global like a uniform
epsilon approximation because the space
is very large and if you want that kind
of results usually you can only get
those countries out in the tabular
setting it's we'll see some of the
reasons why you can't get it in a
function path depending on your
depending on your scenario but I would
argue that this is a reasonable scenario
right this is like you're doing dialogue
systems while you want to satisfy the
customer when they call my fresh
starting from a new accession you don't
you don't really care about it like
someone else is doing a session and in
the middle they hand the session
okay so again this is just some visual
illustration which I'll go over quickly
so so basically if you think about this
like this whole learning problem in like
video game playing right so you think of
like this video game as like a huge MVP
is like a huge like a stochastic graph
controlled stochastic graph and for each
and each screen will be a node in this
in this graph and they're interconnected
with each other and essentially what
you're doing when you do a value
function approximation is that you
extract some features from these game
screens and write on a parametric
function for example using a dip in your
net or and you hope to find the
parameter theta such that the function
represented by the the parameters theta
is a good approximation of Q star and
roughly what you're doing is that you're
trying to find this F theta by by
finding the theta such that F theta
approximately satisfy the bellman
equation induced from the data so I'll
go into details of that procedure in a
second
okay so this is our learning goal and
now I can like reek of like ask the same
question that I asked from the beginning
again in a slightly more formal manner
there's two some missing pieces but more
formally so basically say can we we are
we want to know if it is possible to
learn a good-ass that induce a good
greedy policy with a sample size or
sample complexity that is polynomial in
a number of things I want to grab some
wild to the other standard pack
parameters and horizon for the problem
and logarithmic dependence on the size
of the portion class and as I said like
people have been studying this for like
long long time so we do have some
positive results and have some very good
very good understanding this problem so
from what we know in the literature the
answer is yes we can achieve this sample
complexity but only under two additional
assumptions and what I'll be focusing on
the rest of the talk are exactly like
what those assumptions are and what are
the implications okay so you need two
assumptions here the first assumption is
on data like basically you need data to
be exported you know and export or in
the sense that turns out that you need
something like no policy will induce the
distribution that is too different from
the data distribution you find that
shortly the other assumption and we will
see that this this assumption is the
actually is necessary in some sense in
in in the sense that if you remove this
assumption altogether you can you can
prove exponential lower bound against
this setting so learning is inefficient
in the worst case the more interesting
and more kind of like a miss mysterious
assumption is the second one that says
that my function class does not like
even if I have a realizable function
class that's not enough I need something
that's much stronger and one typical
assumption people make is to say that
this F function class is closed under a
particular operator called the bellman
update operator so if I have these two
assumptions
I can prove this polynomial sample
complexity but it turns out that we
still don't know like why we like is it
that we really need this assumption over
here or can we remove it altogether and
by studying that it turns out that
investigation into these issues review
some very interesting applications
I guess it's like with these assumptions
these are things at least like Poli and
these parameters are the best you can
hope for
so lower bounds I mean so so first of
all like ro is like strictly more
difficult than like supervised learning
so you can't get better than log out
there's there should be a horizon
dependence but OB you're talking about
that even distribution
oh I'm assuming for simplicity that we
get these two poor data where si is aid
is ID from it's a exploit or a
distribution or like we win we will need
to define it without getting to the
learner so the learner may or may not
know mu I I think most algorithm are
agnostic to the knowledge of MU but
really it doesn't really matter here
it's the first assumptions on the data
okay so here is this it is the
assumption how do we yeah so you were
saying that the data assumption is is
necessary that things are pretty close
to MU but that's only in this batch or
all setting yes pretty clear that there
are easy case
we're a little bit of exploration can
can't get a much better bound so I see
you're saying that so I think that's
that's an open problem I think I'm still
thinking about it it's like like if you
have bash data and you give much you
give yourself a little bit of extra
exploration came to you like much better
dad and will be like actually
contrasting the batch setting to the
exploration setting so this is the so
the first assumption says the following
okay so mu is our data distribution so
this is just the illustration of a
distribution over state action pairs and
what you're consider is that you
consider any policy PI that you want to
consider for example with the greedy
policy of your candidate value functions
and you compare these two distributions
and in particular you take any state
action and you compute the ratio between
the densities of these two distributions
so what do you say is that okay let's
see P an uniform upper bound on this
density ratio and I want to make the
assumption that C is more like say C is
constant or in other words I'm happy to
pay say polynomial dependence on the C
parameter so basically what I'm saying
is that I want my data to be
sufficiently like have sufficient
coverage so that for any state action
pair that can a policy want to visit
with high-density I also provide like a
large enough density for that state
action pair yes are you talking about
that exactly like an entry sighs yeah so
this is a kind of yes exactly that I
don't know how to pronounce I forgot the
name but yes I think you need a poor
large class of policies for yes and
we'll see an example turns out that so
what we show in a paper is that so
basically this is something the
assumption you know that it's necessary
because if you remove this assumption or
in other words if C is unbounded or you
don't you you just there exists a
exponential or not but it's actually the
the nature of this lower bound is pretty
subtle which I'll explain shortly okay
so so so first of all there's a trivial
failure mode when you don't assume a
upper bound on the C parameter right so
let's say my data looks like something
like a spike over here I want to give
you data for a single stay there I
should pair and data is missing
everywhere else okay of course you can't
learn because the data is not
sufficiently exploratory right so so
that's an uninteresting failure mode
which we won't Eve remove or exclude in
the first place so the more interesting
question to ask here is what if we just
choose the data distribution like
favorably right so someone give us a
sufficiently exploit or data like the
most exploratory data ever if that's the
case can we just remove this assumption
altogether so the interesting saying
that we see here is that the answer is
actually no so the reason that the
answer is no is because this assumption
is not only an assumption about data
which actually takes me a long time to
realize is that this assumption is both
an assumption on the data and also on
the MTP dynamics and here's why
right so this assumption talks about it
talks about the relationship between two
these two distributions and this
distribution or this there
actually many such distributions for
this red curve that are induced by
different policies and that's induced by
the MPP dynamics so the assumption that
C is finite or C is small it's actually
saying a lot of things about the end
underlying dynamics of the MVP and in
particular if the MVP dynamics are
unregulated it can be the case that even
you will choose the most favorable
favorable distribution no sample
efficient learning can exist and just to
give you a sense how quickly to go over
this so here is the proof sketch so
basically what you do is that you
construct the exponential tree and such
that one of the leaves are more
rewarding than all the other leaves okay
so basically this is like a modern
painted with exponentially many arms so
without further assumptions you can't
get away well you must suffer like
exponential in horizon sample complexity
and what you can do is that you can
construct the realizable F that is small
such that the logarithmic size of this F
doesn't explain away the hardness of
learning and we will be talking about
like stronger assumptions on the
function class but it turns out that
it's still like very easy to studies to
satisfy all those assumptions in this
like exponential tree example well
exponentially H is not okay here right
so we want like yeah yes well if you if
it's X if you have exponential age you
can just try you can just literally run
it as a multi-armed bandit with
you mean by always for any MVP in if
it's finite horizon you can really run
out my damn appendix behind ik algorithm
the destiny starts States selects the
context oh so you were saying that if
you give me exponential sample
complexity how can I
is there an upper bound so here is the
upper bound if then if their horizon or
the number of actions horizon is five
okay so here here is the upper bound
okay so what do you do is that you take
actions uniformly at random at each time
step and you crack law up data and use
the data to do importance sampling over
territories to evaluate each policy
right so so but but but in that case I
would I would ask for like uniformly
random I mean so they're there so I
guess that I guess the thing in that
cake
you can take this offline but but I
think is it's it would like that
algorithm won't work or so yeah in these
slightly different product open since
Irish
okay so so basically if you constructed
this example you realize that this
function approximator basically doesn't
help you at all
so the hardness of learning still exists
and in particular you realize that this
harness is against any algorithm that
can actually have interactive access
with the environment we are interested
in the bachelor in setting and a final
step of the proof is the observation
that in this problem the only thing that
is unknown is the end is the terminal
reward and the dynamics are purely
deterministic and known okay so in this
family of problems any any passion
algorithm combined with any data
distribution can be emulated by and by
an agent or learner that interactive
that actively interact with the
environment because if you want to
sample a sample transition from any
state it can just play that action
sequence to get to that state and
generate the sample so the the hardness
of learning transfer to the to the
bachelor on a setting so which means
that there just doesn't exist a exploit
or a distribution none of their learning
distribution would work in this which
really motivate or really necessary it's
the that we need to consider Mbps with
more kind of like smooth dynamics so
this is really like assumption on both
the data and the MDP dynamics and
someone just asked that what are
examples where this assumption will hold
right so here is a one canonical example
and I think like Monte will probably
talk about a very similar model in her
talk so you can consider like a large
Mbps
where the transition matrix so basically
you put this transition probabilities
into as Abe is big matrix and if this
matrix has a low rank there will always
exist a export or distribution and in
fact it that kind of exploit your
distribution can be generated by a like
like a mixture of actual distributions
that you can induce by taking some of
the policy
okay so this is like if you want any
like concrete example of like where this
assumption holds like a low-rank MVP
will be your canonical and another
interesting thing is that include new
low rack MVPs and a few and other
examples so these kind of like
structures are also structures that
enable efficient exploration algorithms
with value function approximation which
we actually discover so discovering
papering ice mi-17 actually I talked
about this paper a couple years ago here
at the Simons
so this interesting connection allows us
to kind of I compared The Bachelor nice
Eddie an exploration setting
side-by-side and I will talk about some
of the interesting applications later if
you want so okay so I guess this is
mathematically right conquered example
but I guess if you're maybe asking for
more like practical so I guess I'll give
one example is like exact one example
that we often give is these kind of like
a visual grid world that you finding RL
benchmarks where the dynamics are
defined over a small 8 hand state space
let's say you're just doing navigation
tasking like a grid road but what you
don't deserve which grit your Ain and
instead like let's say the entire thing
is rendered in some game engine and you
observe like overall pixel images that
gives you like first-person view of the
environment so that kind of environment
will have like these kind of iCal or
extra sure because the rank will be
determined by the number of Grist not by
the like the pixel images and the other
thing you can imagine is something like
a dialog systems were so these like low
rank
hidden factors are can be things like
the intention of the users interest so
the low rank assumption basically what
happens is that when you do the
transition you start from the as a a
transition us prime you go through like
a bottleneck and like it's the hidden
factor
and conditional hidden factor the next
date distribution is like like
independent of like all the previous
things and basically what happens in
these kind of environments is that for
any distribution that can be naturally
generated over the entire state action
space you can always factorize that you
can always express those distributions
as the distribution over the hidden
factors and then that kind of like
uncontrolled emission process so that
when you compute these densities it's
essentially the density goes over those
hidden factors not over this more it
doesn't depend on exactly like or you
can upper bound that C by the number of
hidden factors or the rent here because
this is kinda like it more like an ohm
then the the assumption that we
understand relative oh wow I do want to
get to the more interesting assumption
that we still don't quite understand
okay so if you if you if you agree with
me that we said okay okay at least like
we need some of these kind of my
assumptions on the data and on the
environment and in other words we're
happy to pay this polynomial dependence
on the C parameter here okay so now we
ask the question again can we get this
sample complexity with realizability
alone or we need much stronger
assumption okay so that's the really
like the open question that I've been
attacking like on and off for a long
time and we still don't know and it's
actually a very interesting question
okay so what I would do next is that
I'll get into a concrete algorithm and
help you understand a little bit why
realizability alone isn't may not be
enough right so if you think about this
assumption it from like a standard
learning theory perspective like
realizable it is this crazy like strong
assumption that no one wants to make and
like it turns out that when you get to
the RL and this is the weakest possible
assumption that you can end up with and
it's likely insufficient
so the particular algorithm that I will
be considering is particular duration
just to refresh for people who are
familiar with fqi you don't actually
need to like understand this algorithm
but just for people who know this
algorithm so basically what you do is
that you you you try to use your
function class to approximate the
valuation procedure you utilize your
function of arbitrary and every
iteration you convert your RL data set
into a least square regression data set
where you set where the input is the
state action pair and the output depends
on the function of the previous
iteration we call this part the
empirical bailment update based on the
single data point and you do a RM over
this over this data set using your
function class and that's the the
argument is the next iteration of the
function and you repeat this ok so
basically this is a one-line description
of this entire algorithm again you don't
need to understand this because the next
example I will show is like much simpler
than all this okay so let's so what I
would describe to you now is how
realizability
if you only assume realizability how can
this simple algorithm just completely go
round in the worst case okay before I
tell you how it goes around let me first
tell you briefly like how it works it's
actually a very simple so so this is
like a simple example you have a chain P
P there like just 10 states you start
from state 1 and there there's no action
there or there's only one action that
moves you forward for forward and at the
end you get a Bernoulli reward that's it
okay and so basically like for now our
data set because there's only one action
I'm gonna admit the action the data set
so your data set would look like
something like I saw promised a number
one I get zero water in transition to
state number 2 and so on so forth and at
the end I get a random reward is either
1 or 0 and the process terminates ok
basic view wrong something my fqi or
anything TD like on this process on this
problem it looks like the following
right
so you start from the very end and you
get data that looks start from number
ten and gives you a render reward you
average the rewards you get an estimate
of the value of state number ten let's
say is something like five point one
point five zero one okay and you could
then you go to the previous time step
you get beta that looks like nine zero
reward transition to state number ten
you convert that into the regression
data set that says state number nine
probably has a value of zero point the
value that you just learned for state
number ten and you do the regression
over that and you learned that state
number nine probably has this value as
well and it's so on so forth and
eventually we learned that okay stay
number one probably has a value of point
zero one okay so this is how like this
algorithm works in this simple example
and in fact almost all dynamic
programming based algorithms that learn
from bootstrapped targets well we well
degrees to exactly the same behavior on
this simple example so we're actually
considering a large family of methods
here so this is working all fine so how
can things go wrong okay so this is
working on fine because this is not
actually the function approximation
setting this example we're allowed to
make any predictions where we're able to
predict any number for the value of any
state so to mimic the difficulty of
function approximation in the next
example I'm gonna restrict the possible
values that the learner can predict for
every single state although I only have
a small number of states okay so in
particular for state number 10 I'm I'm
gonna say the learner can only predict
from these two values and for number
nine these two values and so on so forth
okay now let's run the algorithm again
and see what happens so first a number
10 things are the same so I can predict
five point zero one so everything is
fine so I'm good now since in this
transition I get the data the regression
data set I get is like state number nine
probably has a value
Oh point five zero one but I can only
report from 0.5 either 0.5 or 0.5 0 2
and they are equally distant to my label
so by anniversary road tiebreaking I
could possibly just choose like 5.0 2
and similarly if you if you realize that
basically I'm constructing this example
with the function class so that this gap
between these two values are growing
exponentially over and every time
despite hi break and you can choose the
wrong answer which doubles the error
that you incur in the previous time
staff and eventually you get a
ridiculously large prediction at initial
State
any other words if you run this
algorithm and you want to get a
reasonable absalom approximation at the
initial stage you need to see this
reward exponentially many often and
furthermore although this function class
is constructing at a bathroom manner you
do we do satisfy realizability
because point 5 is the right answer okay
and this example is actually given with
Christine in one of our papers to 2018
and actually like results of similar
nature has existed for like long time
right so if you look at like some of
they've already worked by Ben boy like
Johnson cyclists there there are a lot
of like divergence examples of dynamic
approximate dynamic programming but I
think this this this example is not like
a more intuitive and more plain yeah so
so basically yeah good a good question
but but the thing is that you can easily
extend this counter example to a policy
fine you write it so you can add another
initial stay at a new initial State over
here where you can choose between two
paths and if you have the wrong like a
largely wrong position of the the value
of this path it can you can easily
translate that translate that to a
policy boss
yeah yeah I mean I mean this is a very
stylized yes function approximator so
typically you know what I'm able to what
values I'm able to assign to state one
they're tightly tied for what values
that I find a linear box read indeed
never what happened right you've always
got this tension this is trade off right
so I like to push state one down to two
but that's they are they are but well
actually I so not sure this answers but
so I mean at least directly you need ooh
yes but I'm just trying to get a sense
of for more realistic classes of
approximating to people using practice
right can you kind of construct this
civil so that's unclear we only have
this style as the example and I think
the inertia we have these player small
exam but we don't have a example in
there anyway so basically I'll skip this
but basically what happens is that you
can fix this when you introduce much
stronger assumptions on the functional
class in particular you can say you know
like if my function has is close on our
Perlman update and in this example it
means that whatever predictions I'm
allowed to make for one level I need to
be able to make the same predictions at
a previous level and if this happens
I'll be able to control error and error
won't blow up when you approximate
dynamic programming this assumption
seems like a very strong because it's a
closeness assumption so it can be
violated even more severely when you get
a richer posture pass meter that's
pretty bad so so basically it turns out
that we have so just a they I'm running
out of time just like quickly go through
the rest of the talk so we have a
reasonable strong like evidence to show
that realizability is not enough so what
I really want is to prove a information
theoretic lower about this is that if I
only have realizability this is not
enough okay
it turns out that this bounty is like
surprisingly hard to prove
and I'll give you like a quick sense of
like how proof attempts can fail so the
first attempt fails like just as how you
prove like lower bounding information
theory what you usually do is that you
construct a exponential large family of
hard instances and try to somehow like
induce harness from there and I can tell
you that in this example if that's all
you do you already failed you don't even
need to tell me what your construction
is and the reason is because the
following in The Bachelor resetting
model base are all can succeed under
realizability alone so if all you
construct is a family of hard instances
and you do not impose any further
restrictions you can't prevent an
information theory right learner to be
model ease you know and more concretely
you can actually construct a slightly
bigger f-prime from the model class
that's satisfy those strong
representation conditions so and we do
have some idea of like how to impose
this restriction that the learner has to
be value based and particular one thing
you can do is to say the learner does
not observe the state directly but
instead it can only access the states
through the evaluation of candidate
value functions and it's actually a very
interesting mechanism that we have used
before to show a separation gap between
value based and model-based are now in
the exploration setting and there has
been some like related results but turns
out that in this particular setting if
this is the only mechanism is still
doesn't work and I have a like a laundry
list of like like a lot of requirements
that you just satisfy to get a viable
kind of like instruction and I it's not
that I have a construction I don't know
how to prove the lower bound I don't
even have a construction that assessed
by the like all this
okay so I'm getting into it this is the
only two slides that hacked so why do I
care about this okay so I want to talk
about a little bit about the high-level
implications so really this this lower
bound the resolvent statement of the
restoral bond is particularly
interesting if you look at the larger
picture that compares - RL versus online
expression of RL and also value based
and the model base RL so like in so we
know that we need to assume like smooth
dynamics and for bachelor knee we need
to assume export your data so that part
is kind of like comparable and now if
you look at their representation
condition so there's a very if this
harness conjecture is true we'll get a
very interesting gap between for example
batch RL and online RL because we've
previously shown that if you have smooth
dynamics when you do only exploration
with value function approximation you
only need to realizability
okay and if we realizable living alone
is not enough for batch turning it tells
you that with value function
approximation being able to actively
interact with the environment and
experiment with the environment gives
you a lot of power then mitigate this
harness related to the representation in
summary there can be like a gap between
value Bazaar Elle and model-based RL if
the harness contractor is true so this
is why the the contractor itself is
important on the other hand if I
remember the browser voice is okay if
you you need to assume that Lobell moran
right lobe a meringue so maybe miss that
then I would be happy to talk about
offline but low bomber I guess somewhat
comparable to this like smoothness of
dynamics over here so those two are
comparable to each other and for example
like when you have low rank MVPs both
these and this assumption holds
this is a last I promise
so the other thing that is interesting
is that not only the conjecture itself
is interesting but if the conductor can
be proved the construction will be also
highly interesting for the following
reason so all the lower bound
construction we have currently having
literature of RL all of them basically
actually exhibit a bandit structure so
this is what we how we prove a lower
bound for like tabular MVPs and this is
what we prove for T's like large MVPs so
this is just a mounted on bandit once
there this is a Mountie on bandit like
where's the explenation minimus yes
actually none of those constructions
reflect the interesting and challenging
setting of RL where you have more except
decision-making and the intermediate
feedback signals are informative like
here you get like only informative like
intermediate feedbacks we really are
always interesting when you get
implemented or maybe yes and also the
problem has to be seriously stochastic
and it turns out that there are other
open problems in RL that are also
craving for these kind of interesting
counter examples for example Agora had a
open problem in code that discuss why
there there seems to be missing a write
horizon dependence in tabular pack and
the pack ntp literature and also some on
you probably also talked about this so
if you have linear value function
approximation and you do exploration we
don't know if if you can get efficient
learning if you don't want to assume
like a linear function approximation and
don't assume any anything else and I
think if the if the counter example
exists it will be highly similar to
whatever we use to prove this conversion
and with this I want to conclude my talk
and I hope to resolve these open
problems in the future and hope
for one quick question about the next
speaker prepares if the MVP is
deterministic yes yeah so that's the
part I skip so when you do about a
function approximation if the MVP is
deterministic there's a very simple
algorithm you can do that you can
succeed on the realizability alone so
basically what you do so basically the
difficulty so what do you do is that you
can literally just estimate the bellman
error like directly and with stochastic
dynamics you cannot do that because if
you remember in bellman equation the
expectation is a conditional expectation
it's that conditional on the single
state action pair is the annoying thing
that you can't get over but if the if
the thing is deterministic that
conditional expectation goes away so
what do you do after you estimate the
bellman you minimize it yeah
so you just feel like it's a
straightforward I get a bill my or
minimization and just it works both
theoretically any empirical okay
[Applause]
and that computer is a HUD schmear